So we'll go back to our master material.
We will find some empty space here.
We will hold down M and left click and have it for multiply.
Again these are from the hotkeys that we set at the start but you can just right click
in the menu as well and type multiply and find it there.
But we want to use shortcuts wherever we can.
We want to hold down 3 on the keyboard and left click to create a vector 3.
We want to convert this to a parameter.
Call this tint.
If I can spell color.
I'm going to plug this node into here.
Plug this node into here.
Because it's multiplying it doesn't really matter which way around it goes.
I'm just going to plug it around into there.
And then tint color.
Let's just have a default value of like a bluish type of color just to make sure that
it's got some kind of nice default value and then we'll save that.
And so now because we've saved it and because it's a vector 3 parameter we can actually
hop back into our material instance and you'll see that we've got a nice tint color here
which we can then do whatever we want with.
So slowly we're just layering in the complexity of the materials and adding nice subtleties
and a nice customization for use in our worlds.